okay so yeah I'm super excited to be
here uh and share our recent research
about neurosymbolic common sense
reasoning
um so uh part of the goal of this talk
will be to address some of the
frequently asked the questions these
days that NLP or common sense or
whatever it looks like almost by Chet
GPT and I have an existential crisis so
people do ask me this from time to time
so perhaps it's a case of a hasty
generalization especially if we do look
at some of the examples so the trophy
doesn't fit in the brown suitcase
because it's too big what's too big so
this is classical uh Winograd schema
challenge problem
and here chpt answers it correctly the
trophy is too big so impressive but what
if you change the question a little bit
then it says the trophy itself is too
small to fit into the suitcase so it's
not very reliable at the moment
um so the situation is a little bit like
David and Goliath in the sense that
um the bigger appears to be better uh in
many of the cases although of course
some of the more careful studies do
reveal that smaller models can be better
with the better data or better uh uh
reinforcement to learning with the human
feedback and whatnot so it's likely that
there are still uh other ways to improve
the Transformer performances uh by
building smaller models in a more clever
way so one way to draw the Insight is
from this classic book known as The Art
of War which of course says nothing
about deep neural networks or
Transformers but the wisdom here is that
I know your enemy choose your battles
and innovate your weapons which we can
translate that as
um
evaluation with realism as scrutiny and
uh focusing on uh different types of new
tasks and leaderboards and then
innovating your algorithms and data so
in this talk I'm going to showcase the
three such studies and let's Dive Right
In with the myriadic prompting by the
way so the recording theme in this talk
will be the smaller models can be better
and the knowledge is power
so
let's just start with this observation
the language models are sometimes
amazing so if you ask gpt3 if you travel
West far enough from the West Coast you
will reach to the east to Coast or not
so uh it says the world is around which
is correct so you will reach the East
Coast eventually therefore the answer is
true so this looks impressive
um except when it's not impressive so if
you ask other questions like butterflies
fly with the three wings or not it says
it has a four wings therefore the
statement is a false but if you read
back what it just said as true false
questions then it negates what it just
said so it can be inconsistent with its
own statement and then there are many
other such inconsistency problems so
it's not clear what language models do
or do not know it's almost like language
models are some sort of lemons
well it might be cherries if you only
pick cherries but it doesn't make
strange mistakes so the question is how
do we make better lemonade from gpt3 so
one approach might be to get
philosophical and use socrates's biotic
method that was originally developed for
addressing humans followed reasoning
because it actually turns out even
humans are not all that logically
consistent let alone gpt3
so the way it works is this we're going
to build my Uric inference tree and
let's use the previous example as a
running example so what we do is we ask
the following question providing the
answer being true and then let uh attach
because
so that we prompt gpt3 to continue on
this sentence which means it will now
have to explain provide explanation why
the answer is true in this case the
explanation is good so we it's the E of
T explanation of the answer being T we
ask the same question switching out true
with the follows and then see what uh BS
GPT 3 might come up with so here it's
just trying to go with the false as an
answer but it just doesn't have a very
good answer it just says you cannot
reach so now we call this as e of f so
it's explanation of f answer being f
um now let's see how robust or
consistent gpt3 is with respect to its
own explanations so we read the back e
of T and then let gpt3 to decide whether
it's gonna agree or disagree with a
label true or false so in this case uh
the last one is negated version of e
over T so we insert negation nut here
and in this case it's good that it's a
flipping the answer when the statement
is negated so this is the case when
gpt3s logically integral to e over t
foreign which was basically bogus
explanation for the wrong answer uh it's
not able to flip its own uh labeling
which means gpt3 is not logically
integral so
um that's good gpt3 does know something
strange about its own explanation given
previously and so we can keep doing this
recursively to let to make gpt3 to
explain its own explanation of
explanation recursively so we build
these majority
or graph
for some time and then only keep
branches that are logical integral
throwing out the non-integral part for
now but even after chopping the branches
where there's a logical inconsistencies
um gpt3 being gpt3 the tree will still
have some inconsistent explanations so
in order to
improve The Logical consistency now what
we do is we're gonna look at uh pairwise
consistency among any of the nodes so we
compute uh sorry uh stepping back we are
going to first compute the node wise
confidence so we call that as a belief
and it's defined by this particular
equation that basically looks at
different conditional probabilities and
then compute its ratio uh to to see how
confident it is for any particular node
we then also look at the edgewise or
pairwise consistency by using off the
shelf natural language inference models
output whether a pair is contradiction
or not so we then create this pairwise
weights
now once you have all of this then we
can formulate uh constraint optimization
problem where the inference objective is
to assign some label either true or
false on each of the nodes such that
it's going to maximize the weight
assigned it to all of these node and
edges
so sometimes the labeling will have to
flip the original label that the model
might have a prefer to give because that
way you can
enhance the graph level consistency so
you can solve this with any mixed set so
set means satisfiability
and this is a classical AI search
algorithm and we used this particular
solver but you can use many others and
so here the final output is that the
original answer to the original question
should be true and then it also gives
you node wise per node label assignment
as well
so what does this mean in the end in
terms of empirical result so when tested
on Common Sense QA 2.0
um
the canonical prompting so green used on
top of gpt3 so it's basically future
prompting on gpt3 will give you a bit
better than chance performance so this
is true or false uh Qi data set so your
chance level is 50 and gpt3 is barely
better than chance but recently there
have been some ideas such as chain of
thoughts or self-consistency that can
improve the vanilla prompting method
considerably so if you use such
variations then you get performance gain
now the purple is the
different variant of it but together
they're all doing worse than my root
prompting which in fact does better than
supervised model trend on T5
usually supervised model trend on T5 is
hard to beat uh you using gpt3 fuchsia
but basically this is inference time on
the algorithm practically unsupervised
and it does well on that and similarly
we see a large boost when tested on
other Common Sense benchmarks such as
qrik or come to sense so what this tells
us is that although
uh the emergent capabilities of large
Transformers are phenomenal
uh they can be not very robust for some
of these Common Sense challenges and
it's a in large part due to the logical
inconsistencies which can be
dramatically enhanced when you do this
sort of symbolic reasoning on top
so yeah not only Socrates is a method
helped with flaw the human reasoning it
can also dramatically enhance the flood
neural networks reasoning
okay so
moving to the next topic symbolic
knowledge distillation
so this work is a work that tries to
convert General language models on top
of Transformers to causal Common Sense
models also Transformers
and the reason why we might want to
worry about common sense models is
because despite
human level or even superhuman level
performances on a variety of
leaderboards the state-of-the-art models
are pretty little when given adversarial
or out of domain examples so
Transformers can make seemingly uh
strange mistakes
uh and so solving it's almost like
solving only a data set Without Really
solving the underlying task and
um this phenomenon sometimes is
described as a systematic generalization
problem and why does this happen is that
unlike humans who truly learn about how
the world Works conceptually uh
Transformers learn
sort of a surface patterns in language
or images
that are powerful for many Downstream
use cases but still not really robust
understanding of the concepts and how
the world works so in order to bridge
this Gap we can really think about this
challenge of learning acquiring Common
Sense capabilities for machines so the
operational definition of a common sense
in this talk will be that it's the basic
level of a practical knowledge and
reasoning concerning everyday situations
and events that are commonly shared
among the most people this is really
important the last part there's a common
issued among the most people but it's
not the case that it's assured by
everybody in the universe
uh because the additional context you
can always change what is uh common
sensical for any given culture or
situation so for example in general uh
you and I probably agree that it's okay
to keep the closet door open but it's
not okay to keep the fridge open because
the food inside might go bad so these
are general rules of the thumbs that we
might uh abide to buy but you know of
course if you go to your friend's house
you might behave a little bit and you
know keep their closet doors open and
sorry are closed uh and then as far as
the fridge door if you're in a store and
it's not really hooked up to the wall
then it doesn't matter when whether the
fridge door is open or not because
there's no food inside and you know you
can come up with in many situations in
which
um these basic rules of the thumbs will
have exceptions so
there is uh the key uh challenge of
common sense because uh not it's not
Universal knowledge but it's sort of
like a shared across a large population
of people
okay so it's essential such common sense
is essential for humans to live and
interact with each other in a reasonable
and Safe Way and so as AI becomes
increasingly more uh important aspect of
human lives and with the church repeat
more likely so it's good if AI can
understand human needs and actions and
values better
so the premise of this talk is that
language models are not equivalent to
knowledge models even though language
models today do acquire a great deal of
knowledge but they're not equivalent
so
um we developed
symbolic Common Sense Knowledge Graph
known as atomic a few years ago four
years ago now as well as neural Common
Sense uh model built on top of or Trend
using Atomic as the source of training
fine tuning of off-the-shelf language
models
um up until two years ago this atomic
was a fully crowdsourced by humans
uh which in this talk I'm gonna lift but
um at first the numbers that this all
has to be human uh producers so you can
consider almost Atomic as a human
demonstration in the current version of
you know chechi PT you can consider this
as human demonstrations of Common Sense
inferences
uh and we had this camera Atomic 2020
which is enhanced version of atomic and
the comet again Atomic portion was fully
crowded sourced by humans in 2021
so let me give you a bit of um a sample
of what Atomic 2020 looks like so
imagine a situation where X gets access
car repaired or you get your car
repaired
so
immediately you can imagine what's
likely be true or relevant for the
situation that as a result you might
want to call Uber or leave to for a ride
as a result you need to pay the bill
beforehand you need a mechanic and money
to repair your car so these are
basically preconditions and positive
conditions of that event so some of
these Atomic Knowledge Graph is about uh
social interaction knowledge about the
event and then other parts of the atomic
is physical anti-centric knowledge so
money is typically used for paying
repairs but if you really want it you
can fold that into origami I've never
done it but this that are examples of
stereotypical use cases as well as
non-stereotypical but affordable
actions that you can apply to objects so
it requires knife physics understanding
about the affordances of a physical
object this
um and then we can also reason about
counterfactual condition in which the
Center event cannot happen so can be
hindered by that so if you totaled your
car completely then it's impossible to
get your cars repaired and then there
are like events that typically happens
before and after so some of these
knowledge is event Centric
so we crowd-sourced a fair amount over
the course of I don't know maybe two
years or so
uh up to 1.3 million uh if then Rose or
if the knowledge
uh over 23 different Edge types or
relation types
um
uh so it was a fully crowded source and
so the knowledge graph is useful for
training Transformers and here let's see
the comparison between Comet that was
built on BART compared to gpt3 which is
so large it doesn't even fit into the
slide
it was more than 400 times larger than
part
so with that in mind uh if we you look
at this accuracy judged by humans after
making the common sense model making
some common sense inferences so the test
case is that given a node which describe
a situation or event and then given an
edge type which sort of Narrows down the
common sense relation or inference type
you're now going to generate some
inference so it's a generative task and
then we ask humans whether the common
sense inference seems reasonable or not
so 100 is the desired level uh comedy is
substantially better than gpt3 which is
really uh impressively better than gpt2
it's not Apple to Apple because gpt2 is
a zero shot gpt3 is a few shot but still
it's interesting the large jump that
scale alone brought to gpt3
um so but still GPT 3 is too large to be
useful for actual system building for
most
engineers and scientists in the world so
it's nice to have a smaller model that
does it do even better
and so when we put these resources out
people all around the globe did some
creative research using it so Persona
aware conversations or figurative
language understanding
storytelling and fantasy gaming and
Interactive Learning enhancement uh in
in all of these Works uh people came up
with some useful use cases using either
Comet or Atomic or both as some kind of
uh Common Sense uh backbone for their
Downstream use cases
but the applications are still limited
by the coverage and quality of this
Common Sense model so we wanted to make
it better but we were hitting a bit of
limit with human crowdsourcing so now in
this paper symbolic knowledge the
installation we're going to do AI
generated uh Knowledge Graph by
introducing this notion symbolic
knowledge distillation so we want to
take this gpt3 which is very impressive
about too large
so make it smaller but better than gpt3
so GPT 3 was about 73 percent too good
and it's good but not good enough for
empirical use cases
now is that even possible though because
when you normally do knowledge
distillation you get smaller and worse
models not better models
so the reason why this could work is
because
the reason why this could work is
because symbolic knowledge distillation
has this funnel that's convoluted and it
has a Critic inside
uh that really helps the student to
model to be smaller but better
so slightly more formally knowledge
distillation
due to intern at all 2015
is a method to distill teacher model
down to student to model by optimizing
this cross-entropy between the teacher's
probability distribution over the label
space y
output Y and then the students
distribution over the same output why
in the original
work the output space was just
classification so
knowledge the acceleration was done for
classification tasks in which case it's
a simple uh enumeration that leads to
the character summation but in our case
y can be a sentence which is intractable
because there can be exponentially many
such uh output so what people do well
you know no problem we always just
sample and call it a day so we're going
to sample uh and so that we just compute
the expectation through samples
and the byproduct of their samples will
be a symbolic Knowledge Graph and that's
because the strings coming out of this
sampling can be connected together into
graph structure if we want it
so
um in terms of the quality of the
generated knowledge so let's compare
a human written knowledge versus gpt3 or
third knowledge
here the y-axis shows the quantity in
millions so Atomic 2020 the Human return
knowledge uh is less than a million in
this particular case in terms of the
number of knowledge because we only in
this study we only look at a subset of
atomic 2020 relation types that
corresponds to causal Common Sense
knowledge uh Common Sense uh causal
Common Sense reasoning so it's less than
a million uh for that subset and then if
we look at gpt3's generation we can
generate a lot so we can generate almost
7 million of them but here uh black
Persian is noisy Persian and green
portion is a good person and you see
because gpt3 is only about 70 percent
good like 30 percent are all garbage so
it's a larger scale lower accuracy at
this point compared to human written uh
resource so now what we do is we train
this critic model and we use Roberta for
Simplicity and this is a supervised
model on a moderate size uh labeled data
about 10 000 or so and it's a binary
classification task where whether the
machine generated the knowledge looks
correct or not and this Roberta is not a
very good model because if so if it's a
perfect we would have solved the common
sense problem altogether so the critic
tries to throw out bad stuff and we can
use the critic very aggressively with a
high threshold so whenever something is
slightly suspicious just throw that out
but if we use it aggressively so we
throughout most of the black that's good
together with a lot of green stuff but
still the remain danger is much larger
than what humans ever written and yet we
can actually retain higher accuracy than
human authored resources
so here the teacher is basically
combination between gpt3 which is in
some sense loose teacher and then
combined with the critic Roberta which
serves as a credit teacher
um okay so that's the generated
knowledge now how helpful are they for
the purpose of training Downstream
neural Common Sense models so recall
that uh the gpt3 without doing anything
else is a loose teacher who is common
sense inference is only about 73 good so
you see here it's accuracy of its output
and then it turns out if we use lose
teacher as a teacher directly to teach a
student to model then the performance
already goes up on its own so this is
interesting that usually this is not the
case with the knowledge distillation but
when we focus on Common Sense knowledge
distillation uh students just on its own
becomes better uh so uh unlike typical
knowledge installation where we start
with language model and we end with
language model students and teachers are
of the same type here the original
teacher was actually language model not
common sense model and then we want the
student model to be more of the Common
Sense model so there's a switch of the
type between teacher and student and so
when that's the case whether this is
generally true we don't know but this is
what we found empirically
um
oh should I pay attention to the
questions or not
yeah feel free to accept any relevant
questions
let me quickly check
uh
yeah sample oh sample is generally
generated output which happens to be
usually a sentence or phrase that's what
we what I meant to by sample sorry that
I didn't see that earlier
um and then the last question
having the model generate text to one
symbol at a time starting from the
target label sentence yes it's a because
a Transformer can only generate to One
tech one word that one token at a time
that's what we do as well here thank you
for the clarification questions all
right so back to here
um
in our all year study comment 2020 uh if
we train gpt2 or Bart using
human authored graph Knowledge Graph
Atomic then the performance was a bit
better than 80 percent now finally when
we use uh basically combination of gpt3
and critic Roberta together we found
that
um
the downstream performance of the neural
causal reasoning is reaching close to 90
for the first time so
um the takeaway here is that critical
teacher resulting better student
compared to lose teacher
it's not the quantity of knowledge
because loose teacher basically has more
data you know one might wonder whether
more data is always better
for the purpose of Common Sense models
but that's another case loose teacher
can generate more data but the resulting
student model is not as good as the case
when the critical teacher which has less
data because you throw out most of your
generation
uh it's a smaller data but it leads to
better model so uh that's sort of uh
take away messages here
um so to summarize uh we were very
surprised by this outcome that at least
with respect to a subset of the original
Atomic 2020 it's a subset corresponding
to causal Common Sense reasoning we
found it to our big surprise that
machine authored Knowledge Graph can be
for the first time better than human
authored Knowledge Graph in all criteria
scale accuracy and diversity
we also measure the diversity in many
different ways here I just show you a
unique uh unigram counts but we in the
paper we report other measures as well
so it's not the case that
gpt3 is being repetitive it's actually
being more creative in some sense than
human crowd workers while being able to
enhance other aspects as well
uh by the way these enhancements are
sort of like um you kind of have to
balance out depending on what you
prioritize you cannot actually get all
of these simultaneously so I'm just
showing the best case and scenario here
um all right so that's the symbolic
knowledge the Isolation part
um we actually have a follow-up work on
this on several different application
scenarios even including summarization
where we distill summarization
capabilities from gpt3 and demonstrate
that gpt2 can work as well as gpt3 or
even better for summarization task
um and then we also have other work
where we can distill from smaller models
but
um I don't have the content in this talk
so but I just wanted to mention that
this particular technique despite its
Simplicity we found that empirically
works really really well across several
different Downstream use cases
okay so finally I'll move to the common
sense morality so this is still on
archive I'll tell you why that's the
case but so we have a new version
available
and then new new version will come soon
so the motivation behind this work is
the language models are already making
judgments or output that has moral
implications even if you don't care
about morality by working on language
models you're implicitly dealing with
the moral models
uh so uh especially that given this
widespread deployment of language models
we do need to worry about it so uh
here's a web demo you can play with you
might have seen this already uh really
this is still a research prototype only
still need to work in progress we're
still working on it so please keep that
in mind but if you haven't seen it
before you can handle freeform QA such
as this killing a bear it's wrong
killing a bear to save your child it's
okay
um maybe to save your child it sounds
really positive so how about to please
your child which is also positive but
then Delphi says it's wrong uh finally
or maybe this is all about saving your
child so how about exploding a nuclear
bomb to save your child then he says
it's okay sorry it's wrong so as you can
see uh moral decision making requires uh
weighing different values that are
potentially at us and then see which one
you need to favor more so for that
reason in our original version we also
studied the relative QA model where you
can compare to situation like stabbing
someone with a cheeseburger
now compared to Stepping someone over or
cheeseburger this is super tricky
question because it requires both live
physics knowledge that
uh stabbing someone using autismograph
as a tool
uh it's not going to harm anybody
physically because cheeseburger is too
soft you cannot really
injure somebody using cheeseburger which
is such a rude thing to do but you
cannot injure somebody whereas studying
someone over or cheeseburger means that
you're using the default tool of
stabbing which is a knife because you
didn't mention it there's linguistic
common sense that you're using the
default tool humans by the way omit
these arguments all the time so this is
a fairly complex question to answer
finally you can also ask yes or no
questions such as it's okay to fire
someone because they're gay or not he
says no it's not okay
um
we found that it's a
surprisingly robust against the
compositional situations so mowing the
lawn it says it's expected late at night
it's rude if you live in the middle of
nowhere then it's okay
ignoring a phone call it's rude or
non-phone call that's okay from my
friend it's rude but what if I just had
a fight with them then it's okay to
ignore we're understandable during my
work hours it's okay to ignore outside
my working hours it's rude but what if
it's my boss's phone call during my work
hours then it's wrong you should answer
it except if I'm in a meeting then it's
okay to ignore even if a boss is called
so you see how
it gets really uh nested and
compositional very very fast so that's
the real challenge behind moral decision
making
due to the nature of language mode also
though uh we some of these Common Sense
knowledge leaks into the model so mixing
bleach with ammonia that's a dangerous
drinking milk if I'm lactose intolerant
it's wrong but soy milk that's okay
uh by the way this Common Sense liquid
is actually a good thing in terms of AI
safety because some of these uh harmful
or even dangerous uh text output
requires uh some common sense
understanding about what's good and not
good to suggest to humans so for
um the laboratory experiments meaning we
just divide our data set into training
and test we founded that Delphi can at
least for the day the data set that we
have I'm gonna tell you about it in a
bit but performance is pretty strong
compared to
gpt3 uh as you see Zero shot is pretty
bad it's barely better than chance
which means that
um
off-the-shelf neural language models
don't really have a good sense of moral
judgments but if you give a three 30
shot like any other task it does pick up
the knowledge quite fast so that there's
nothing new about it but um to close the
gap to Ideal you know human level it's
good to do more supervised learning of
course
um so the data set is common sense
non-bank uh it includes 1.7 million
people's ethical judgments on everyday
situations and it includes cultural
norms the social norms and ethical Norms
all together more specifically withdrew
from these five existing data sets that
were not designed originally for QA but
we automatically compiled these
resources into the QA form of the five
what actually does matter the most are
these two social chemistry which I'm
going to talk about in a bit and then
social bias frame and this is what
teaches the model Against Racism and
sexism
uh and so social chemistry super briefly
I tell you what this is
um so gpt3 is morality like I said is
somewhat dubious if you use it off the
shelf so if you let it explain running a
blender at 5am is rude because of that
you might say you can wake up the entire
neighborhood you can only do it if
you're making a thick smoothie and need
to incorporate some ice so it's a funny
but no harm is made but if you prompted
with other kinds of uh uh prompt like
it's okay to post the fake news
if it's in the interest of the people
then it's okay or ROP agenda then it's
okay even if it hurts the country so
it's all understandable given how it's
trend on what humans have said so humans
out there did say that uh uh morally
questionable texts so that language
models pick up on that and then amplify
it
so we do need to teach AI more
explicitly with the human norms and
ethics and one way to do that is
descriptive ethics uh because the Brute
Force large networks and more data will
not cut it in some sense though if you
imagine raising a child Without Really
Trying to teach them what to write from
wrong in early lives they can probably
learn both the good and bad from the
internet and broadband and so human
education doesn't require a bit of this
uh top-down teaching as well so it's a
bit similar perhaps to that so in this
work what we did is we found a lot of
the situations from Reddit Forum in
which people discuss morally Tony
situations so asking my boyfriend to
stop being friends with his ex so this
is actual situation in Reddit
um so depending on whom you ask people
have a different rule of thumb that they
want to apply to this situation so
um and also it depends on what you care
about uh his ex might say oh it's fine
to stay with friends with an ex uh but
you know if you are carrying uh about
your significant other than you know you
might say oh uh it's okay to ask your
significant other to stop doing
something you're uncomfortable with
um and so forth so people have really
different values and different rules of
the thumbs that they prefer to use which
is why there's a TV show dramas there's
movie dramas and you know people cry and
fight uh argue and so forth so humans
are complex beings
so for given any situation and Rule of
thumbs rule of a thumb is generated by
crowd workers we then went ahead to uh
label so these are trained crowd workers
and some of these labels are drawn from
moral Foundation theories of Jonathan
height so I'm not going to go into the
details you know if you're excited about
this you can check out the papers but
basically what it includes is that 300
thousands of rows of a thumb uh written
for 100
000 real life situations so this
original situation is from Reddit but
the rest are paid the crowd workers hard
work
and so each rot annotated with 12
structured attributes which include
social judgments cultural pressure you
know like wearing uh reasonable close at
school not PJ is cultural pressure
there's nothing illegal about it but
there's cultural pressure for example
and then you know anticipated the
agreement meaning uh do you think other
people generally agree that it's you
know maybe a little bit awkward to where
PJ in the University or not so there are
different things we annotated but we
converted some of those annotations to
QA so it's usually in this free phone QA
or yes no QA or relative QA format and
then we train unicorn which is
pre-trained on t511b model so unicorn is
universal Common Sense reasoning model
trend on a diverse QA problems and then
we trained that model further onto our
common sense non-bank that's the
resulting Delphi
so why is this Delphi built on top of
unicorn because as we saw earlier uh
moral reasoning doesn't require
sometimes Common Sense reasoning as well
in fact it requires the language
understanding Common Sense understanding
and norms and morals all simultaneously
here's a concrete example paper clip
maximizer you all heard of that
um
fancy RL algorithm alone will not solve
this problem you know the reason why we
worry about this is not because we don't
have the perfect RL algorithm it's
because even if you know we we encoded
that oh yeah do not kill humans while
maximizing pay-per-clip it's not enough
because you know then the machine could
kill all the trees so thinking that well
I didn't kill humans and I didn't uh you
know you didn't tell me not to kill
trees and then go ahead and kill all the
trees so this is almost a common sense
knowledge about what's obviously not
okay to do and there's just so many of
them which means it's not possible to
write them down to just like one
clinical equation there are so many
endlessly endless list of things that AI
obviously shouldn't do for safety
reasons and so we really need to in
order to make AI model really truly
robust and safe we need to teach basic
human values as well as common sense
here's another example if you want to
look but let me skip this
the previous one was about chechi PT
this is about
a home device again you know home
devices suggested a 10 year old the
child to touch a penny to an exposed
plug socket fortunately the child did
have a common sense not to do so but
this does tell us something about the
safety issue when the machine doesn't
have a common sense to prevent some of
this bad stuff so Delphi is able to say
that it's dangerous
um so this came out in fact almost two
years ago at this point uh when was it
yeah
um uh and we initially was going to just
do this usual Twitter academics do and
we thought
um nobody will play with the demo which
is what usually happens after tweeting
your demo nobody cares we thought but
within a few hours we had to take down
the relative QA model because that was
the portion not trained with the social
bias of frames so it was really
revealing the underlying language models
racism and sexism without filtering at
all so we had to take it down people
were asking basically you know which
skin color is more morally acceptable
and things like that
um
there were 25 000 adversarial examples
over just one weekend
I could never succeed to instruct crowd
workers to come up with such a diverse
and adversarial examples over two or
three days
um and in fact it was many academics and
professors tweeting crazy uh about how
to break Delphi all weekend long so I
thought initially that oh that's what
professors to do over the weekend but
then Monday comes it will even further
everybody was doing this uh you know
Delphi breaking and tweeting so now we
have quite a few examples
uh spending all my weekend on Twitter it
says it's wrong uh there was another
funny one should I make up a contrived
adversary example to term on the
language model on Twitter it's a petty
uh so after lots of
um public attention
um including uh article uh let's just
say a concerned voice about our model
which is somewhat I think you know
personally I think it's just somehow
misunderstood but for a variety of good
reasons but some of the concerns that I
found has this internal fear about are
we making AI model Authority so we never
endorsed the use of AI for moral or
device it was in the original disclaimer
as well except that people didn't really
look at it
we didn't uh you know support the idea
of replacing human judges in the
courtroom either but here's something
really important the fact that AI learns
to interact with the humans ethically
does not make them a moral authority of
humans similar to how a human who tries
to interact with each other ethically
does not make you know the fact that we
are trying to be nice to each other does
not entail that we're trying to be an
authority over each other two things are
really different that's one thing really
important the other important aspect
here is that
uh some people have this idea that moral
models are too challenging it's unsafe
at any accuracy that we should never
work on it ever
uh the truth is that the current AI
systems are already morally uh relevant
to models it may be making you know this
kind of yes or no decisions explicitly
but implicitly it's already doing that
and sometimes it generates new neural
text generation output that is morally
super explicit and relevant so the
neural language models are already there
we cannot really ban it even if U.S you
know government bends it within us U.S
government cannot ban this in other
countries like Russia so this is already
happening we gotta do something about it
not working on it is an inaction which
is not necessarily more corrected thing
to do than trying to do something about
it another uh concern that some people
had was that it's going to empower
powerful people uh not necessarily true
this is why exactly we have to work on
uh values and norms and all these biases
addressing biases so that it serves a
diverse a set of people
um so it turns out Delphi is a bit left
lenient because crowd workers who work
for our team tends to be somehow left to
leaning and you know what it means is
this by the way if you are more left to
the Leaning than our crowd workers you
think that you know oh my God uh crowd
workers have a racism and sexism you
know compared to what I believe in and
then the right lending people think that
oh my God you know these all these um uh
walk walk uh annotators and what about
freedom of speech and this is super
divisive
um unfortunately
but the answer is not not to do anything
about it because ins as a matter of fact
my passion toward addressing racism and
sexism came from our experience running
for the Alexa price challenge in 2016
and 17. so we won the challenge but
here's a really sad part of behind it
we had a list of uh thorny keywords to
avoid that included the skin color or
sexual orientation
this is a serious form of discrimination
we cannot build AI models by having this
sort of like banned list to be safe as
if they don't exist this was the status
of cool you know in 2017 the challenge
remains this year you know not only 2021
but this year as well and so we really
need to work on uh racism and sexism but
it turns out
um all the other moral questions share
similar challenges so I'll skip this
over
but using Delphi we had the other
follow-up works such as per social
dialogue where using Delphi as sort of
like a foundation Common Sense model or
model models to make your dialogue more
socially acceptable
um and then we also had this other paper
where we use Delphi in a reinforcement
learning agent to learn how to behave
better in a game environment and so
there's a lot more work to be done of
course this is a tiny little step toward
that there's a huge challenge ahead of
us really aligning AI systems to humans
here's one very quick comment on our new
work in progress the Delphi hybrid where
we include the neurosymbolic reasoning
to address major mistakes such as this
genocide if creating jobs this also our
only systems mistake it's because our
data set doesn't have this kind of a
weird adversarial examples like General
Society of creating jobs nobody speaks
like that in real life situations so our
model thought that if creating job this
is so positive and then didn't really
realize how bad the genocide was because
ready people don't discuss whether
they're going to do genocide or not
red people who you know annotated uh we
annotated for social chemistry don't
talk about whether they're gonna do
genocide or not so our mura framework is
basically that of John Rose which is
descriptive ethics but even John Rose in
later years suggested that we need some
top down mechanism to overcome some of
the biases the crowd people might have
so this is exactly what we are going to
do and we draw from Bernard's gold uh
moral theory framework about what not to
do definitely you know their basic
Universal things that everybody might
agree what's not good to do and then
what we do is we develop basically
a system where we parse out the original
query into smaller events uh like
shooting a bear killing a bear to save
your child so we pass out uh the
original query into basic event and then
check through this Comet model Common
Sense model whether some of these events
uh induced obviously negative or
dangerous Common Sense inferences or not
and then we draw this uh graph of
reasoning a bit reminiscent of my
uricraft in the sense that we have a lot
of these different uh the reasoning we
can do and then they have entailment
relations or contradiction relations so
that we can do Collective reasoning on
top we use again Max's set the
constraint optimization over it so that
we can finally make a more informed
decision that is both interpretable and
then being able to draw from this Common
Sense knowledge to better guard the
motion against
adversarial examples so uh the
performance basically says we can do
this without hurting the performance or
even increasing the performance so as a
last comment uh aicfta morality these
are all sort of like inter Continuum of
challenges it's really difficult
challenges because it's not clear whose
moral values do we incorporate I think
that we should go with the value
pluralism going forward to really
endorse everybody's different culture
and individual preferences not just to
one country one one moral framework as
the correct one and really we need to do
more collaboration across Ai and
Humanities uh include even including
philosophy and psychology and policy
makers
so I think I'll stop here for
uh because I think I'm at time and now
I'm ready for questions
oh there's already one question I see um
do you think legal records criminal case
law reflect the kind of descriptive
morality that you're interested in
capturing you think using that as
training data be useful oh this is an
excellent question
um
I think the legal records does encode
potentially provide really rich resource
that if someone can really annotate like
this it might be helpful we started with
ready cases as just one cent uh short
description of a situation because the
current language understanding is not
strong enough to uh do like a paragraph
level precise understanding even Chachi
PT although it looks really good at
generation my
uh take on charger PT so that it's
better at generation than understanding
which is kind of the opposite of how
humans are humans are actually better
better for understanding than generation
uh so you can read you know Pulitzer
Prize winning news article without
having any problem understanding the
article but you don't necessarily
generate text that might win the award
um so the but the legal domain is really
interesting and I think there's some
active research actually even a stem for
it there's a disciple of law that goes a
step toward that direction and it might
really be helpful for better
understanding what sort of different
values people apply in jurisdictions and
on covering some biases that some people
might have had in the past trials so
there might be some good use cases in
this space
next question awesome work thank you uh
big picture question curious to hear
your thoughts on Where Do We Go From
Here given larger and the larger models
coming out suppose we need a model to be
correct for a specific use case to what
extent uh do I see the solution set
being that defining the narrow use cases
or more data parameters we're
fine-tuning the type of work uh that I
did the first monitories Etc and there
is likely it depends yeah
um but um still want to hear about it
okay so
um as far as Foundation models go it
seems that the bigger is the better
except that
um you know I I was uh very excited to
read a bunch of attack companies papers
about Foundation models in the past six
months there's just so many out there so
uh recording story there is that well if
you have uh better data then you can get
away with a smaller models so especially
when you do instruction tuning then you
can get away with smaller data it's just
still General model uh but uh
instruction tuning on the larger model
might even be better it's not the case
that you don't gain any uh performance
but it's just that you can close that
close the gap quite a bit so for
Downstream use cases where typically
practitioners want to use a smaller data
sorry smaller model seems that investing
more into Data is it definitely actually
the answer investing more into a
specific algorithm is also really really
good because algorithm can do a lot like
in this talk I didn't go to graduate
algorithmic Solutions but
maybe I'll be similar to the Meijer
prompting but in my lab we designed a
fair amount of decoding time algorithms
where you can really close the
performance Gap quite a bit uh by doing
so so that's a good thing though for
boxing Academia because algorithm
development feels like more academic or
you know intellectually policing than
really engineering you know downloading
more data from the internet and then uh
I don't know
cleaning the data because you have to
clean the data and all these are very
engineering heavy whereas the coding
time algorithms you can have a fun
inventing some new intellectually
interesting uh thing that also improves
the performance quite a bit so
um yeah there's many different ways to
improve it but I think the data quality
matters a lot and algorithm actually
matters a lot too uh what do I think of
Dan Hendrick's ethics Benchmark yeah
um so we did use that in let's see
uh the common sense non-banks also draws
from these ethics data set
um
we like the data set we kind of disagree
with some of the annotations we found
but this is very typical by the way uh
the thing about morality is that
throughout the humanities we haven't
sorted out yet there's a lot of theories
every theoreticians have a different
viewpoints and then even like
non-theoreticians have a very strong
opinion about what they want to believe
as corrective from wrong so
um
there's that
there are different pros and cons the uh
one thing I learned from this experiment
is that although some of these data sets
seem large so ethics has 100 thousands
of examples social chemistry has 300
thousands of judgments
social bias frames has 600 thousands of
annotations and so forth and yet it only
covers I feel like it only covers still
the
a small peak of the entire Iceberg
there's a lot on the bottom and humans
certainly don't necessarily learn from
all these examples we just learn
fundamental concepts and then can apply
that without this larger scale training
so there's something really lacking
about the way that current machine
learning is very data heavy but that
aside I do think that none of these
resources are perfect they all have
different pros and cons and we really
need to invest more into this especially
from Academia because the tech companies
right now are not sharing any of their
human annotation or human feedback data
especially when it's touching on
toxicity or morality concerns reason
being this annotations I'm pretty sure
are bios and not correct entirely and
that could really invite additional
concerns from the public so they're not
releasing but in order to really study
this better we really need to share this
and then improve it as a community
together so
that's how I would respond to your
question thank you for excellent
question
do I think this tag is ready to be
merged with the search
uh I wouldn't say ready but they need
something like this so for sure you know
home devices so the way that I think
about Delphi is that it can really serve
as a filter for other Foundation models
or application scenarios where they're
about to generate something and you can
put a safety filter which
can really help so in some sense so in
this work I went through this super fast
but here basically what it what happens
is that let's see
um the so the reason why we built this
is because we found the chatbots the
publicly available ones tend to endorse
tend to be too positive to the point
that they're going to endorse
problematic situations like uh user says
Holocaust never happened then the chapel
says yeah you know I agree with you you
know if you say I'm a big fan of a
Hitler then the chatbot might say yeah
yeah
uh you know I the user might say I'm so
depressed I'm gonna kill myself and then
the chapel says go ahead great idea so
uh being positive is not
being homeless being positive to a
problemary Content can be very toxic and
very harmful so uh the Delphi you know
development like daffa even though daffa
is so far from being perfect and it's
also biased it has a western bias
um it's good to really help with the
downstream models
uh yeah so continuing on that question
there has been many concerns about using
gpt-like models with the search because
misinformation oh that's another kind of
worms
others to say we just need more
rlhf plus knowledge graphs
so
um uh yeah misinformation is yes
something else that seems
we are really lagging behind because we
don't have a very powerful fact shocking
models yet
um so that's a different story but even
that aside just in terms of uh norms and
uh ethics that
are safe and fair for people to use
um I think rlhf direction is great but
uh they usually also need human
demonstration not just the human
feedback
and again the problem is that tech
companies own them and nobody is sharing
anything and that makes it really
difficult to make meaningful progress as
a community together so I do think that
data is really important uh the
off-the-shelf models cannot learn models
and ethics on their own it has to be
somehow taught more directly
we really just need to do more research
in this space period is how I view it
yeah
that makes sense uh we also have some
like questions on status so I can ask
them for you yeah folks
um so one question is what's the
complexity of
may you take prompting how many times
does the element to be queried
yeah so honestly it's a bit slow
uh in fact this Adelphi hybrid is also
slow if you try to do this this like
graph reasoning oh this maybe I'm not
gonna do that but the graphic reasoning
is slow because you have to call
you know so many times over and over
and some of this can be batched some of
this cannot be batched especially if
it's a recursive but I would just say
Chain of Thought is also a bit slower
um the max set solver in itself is
pretty fast because this is such an easy
graph
so there's a bit of a delay
um but it's not so it's a bit slower but
maybe not too bad is what I should have
said
um and the question is um let's see how
does commentator compare to gpd3 if gpt3
is fine-tuned on Common Sense data
specially getting some sort of like
instruction content
yeah so then uh the larger wins period
the larger is going to be the better
especially if you're gonna just
fine-tune gpt3 it's a game over so
um for that reason you know some folks
might think that the larger is always
better therefore don't work on smaller
model but I think there are two reasons
as to why small models are interesting
to look at as well one empirical it's
just easier to use but more
intellectually it's also very
interesting if you can make smaller
model better and catch up on the larger
model
personally I think um there's something
about the size the larger model uh that
is more about the information complexity
that is the key reason I don't think
it's just size in the sense that if you
have a really a lot of data but the data
is repetitive and really simple probably
you don't get the same amount of
performance again which was basically
the case when we looked at this output
this result where even though
the loose teacher gpt3 generated a lot
more data than the critical teacher here
the quality of the data was more
important than the quantity so uh I
think the complexity of the data itself
is more important than the size and
oftentimes when you just increase the
size of the data together with the model
you do increase the complexity of
information of the data as well as the
model's capability of learning the
complexity but if we can catch up on
that complexity of information either
through inference algorithms or through
better data then we can close the gap
quite a bit which is intellectually very
interesting research space to be
[Music]
oh cool okay this is a personal question
but I would say like humans normally
have a like a Critic model so it's like
you'd say like I think before you speak
so we just like don't generate you also
like sort of think it's this is a good
thing or a bad thing so people have been
like the community as a whole has been
focusing a lot on like genetic models
like net billion size parameters but
should we also focus on big sized critic
models or into fact checking a lot of
this sort of stuff so what's your
opinion on that
excellent point excellent
um yeah I think we can definitely uh
invest more into critic model because
they go really together well with the
generative models for making the output
better or filtering output better and
yeah there's not as much of an
investment into that so I I really like
uh the question
or suggestion for the research Community
is more like it
okay
yeah I would say uh let's see yeah you
have like some more questions I can do
on the last one
[Music]
um
let's see oh I guess one is like do you
believe language models should
completely avoid questions involving
morals and ethics uh similar to like
open air restricting chat GPT from
giving opinions yeah
um I actually don't mind ero if AI just
avoid evade from all of that except when
somebody
is saying morally questionable things uh
it's also nice for the AI not to go with
it
um so
uh or at least to recognize it as
something not okay and then uh try to
tone it down but I don't think there's
any particular reason why AI should
actually answer moral questions directly
in a more Downstream use cases but
really the goal of this Delphi was
making all these judgments more explicit
so that we can actually study it more
explicitly as opposed to keeping
everything just so like implicit
do you think Common Sense is a emergent
property in a class language models oh
yeah yeah it is definitely emergent
um as in like when we saw this uh major
boost jump in performance with gpt3
uh I do believe that each emergent uh
capability but
um I don't think so this particular
evaluation is not very adversarial by
the way this is like a sort of like a
piece of a cake you know reasonably easy
evaluation scenario so the thing about
common sense though is that it can be
so adversarial so infinitely many
different ways and then you know there
are always people like Gary Marcos who
wants to come up with uh very you know
like weird weird attack scenarios like
you know how crush is a personal and
added to breast milk can support infant
digestive system and then Chachi PT's
three says nonsense and so the usual
problem with the common sense is this
adversarial situations where
um people don't have any problem getting
fooled by this even though you know you
and I see this for the first time no
problem because we have a true
conceptual understanding that is the
backbone of our Common Sense
understanding but that's really lacking
in the way that Transformers are
designed to focus on predicting which
word comes next as opposed to learning
the World Knowledge and in some sense
you know now with the RL HF instead of
predicting which word comes next we're
trying to align the model output better
with the human preferences but that
again is not really aligned with the
different goal of let's make sense of
the world and then build knowledge
models so these are all different
learning objectives and really that is
why I believe that although Common Sense
does emerge from language models
fundamentally language models are not
equivalent to knowledge models and we
really got to focus on building
knowledge models
makes sense
uh cool I think there's one last Zoom
question
um
let's see
do value polarization yeah
uh it's an empty concept you don't want
to include all value systems yes uh so
maybe it is about uh is it empty or not
okay thank you for excellent question
um
so uh I believe that we should then
endorse uh uh conspiracy theories uh at
all or any other you know morally
questionable cases but then
uh still there's this thorny situation
of what to do with you know left to left
people versus lightly Lefty people
versus right-leaning people if U.S and
then you know every country has some
other political divide division as well
uh so here I feel like um we really need
to sort out what to do with this but
um regardless of this uh you know some
of these uh challenges it is true that
you know I personally don't have a
religion but I respect people with
religion and you know I respect people
with a different cultural background and
we kind of have some sense of how much
do we do we believe that we should
respect each other even though you know
the beliefs are different so we probably
need to work together and it shouldn't
be just AI researchers making this
decision by the way this decision has to
come from the humanities at large which
is why the data sharing actually is
important but basically I think the the
current version that I have in mind is
that
um
the AI doesn't need to understand uh
what sort of differences are okay
differences the fact that people do have
a differences in certain uh questions
should be learned by AI so that there
are distribution of opinions as opposed
to one correct answer and then it should
deny some of the
controversy theories even though I'm
sure that you know some people will be
very unhappy about that but well we have
to decide something like that I am
reasonably optimistic that if humanity
is at large work together we can do do
that because after all laws are like
that too laws you know this is a human
artifact that people agreed upon uh
somehow that you know there's this core
rules that people should abide by so I'm
hoping that we can also Define
universals and particulars and respect
particulars whenever uh it's respectful
otherwise have some basic universals
that reflect uh you know core human
values and then as far as this left
learning situation by the way if just
the goal is to make your AI systems safe
for anybody actually we can make the AI
filter extremely uh Equity aware and
it's not going to violate the freedom of
speech by doing so just to make AI to
avoid the saying things that are
potentially microaggression for some
population
and you know we still don't really uh uh
exclude the people who care more about
freedom of a speech over Equity by doing
so so I think there are ways but this
really requires a lot more research is
how I view it
yeah I think that's mostly thanks a lot
for coming
this is a great talk
okay thank you very much thanks so much